believe it or not a male contraceptive
pill is coming out yeah that's right
researchers announced discovery of
proteins that can be blocked to prevent
the launch of sperm cells during
ejaculation calm down guys it'll knock
out the proteins in genetically
engineered mice which resulted in male
animals that were completely infertile
though they continued to mate normally
so basically the sperm can't get into
the semen so you can have as much sex as
you want and you are not going to become
pregnant this opens up a Pandora's box
of issues I will go to the lady on the
panel first you kind of thing will you
trust a man and that's the thing like I
think this is amazing advancement I mean
all we do first of all in this society
is put money more money than we could
even imagine into men's penises yeah you
know with Viagra and Cialis and pumps
and whatever you people do and I could
think we're right here but I mean we the
penis industry is booming so why don't
we do something that actually could you
know help in other ways as well and I
think it's great and I know that men are
afraid to take contraceptive because our
new boats gonna put my body I don't know
how about every way it affects our
bodies but we do it because we want to
protect ourselves and not add to the
population for a million reasons but I'm
ultimately the one that has to you know
worry about it so if you're like no no
baby it's all good I left my a magnum XL
zat home I got this covered there is no
way in hell I'm going to trust you to
deal with my body right so you brought
up like 20 great things their first up
we've up we have a whole industry based
on getting the penis in this is the
first thing that deals with what happens
once it's actually in there but what but
what about the trust issue really I
think that's a that's a legit thing if a
woman's taking the pill she knows she's
done her her due diligence when she's
having sex uh but how can she trust the
guy any guy not just a one-night stand
you be the guy for months even if he
forgets to take it or whatever it is
what responsible fathers tell their sons
I mean back in our old world since for
old folks now yeah tell our sons I you
know don't trust him when she says she's
on the pill men don't trust her she's
trying to get you sunstrike get your
money
right so if that's already the thing
that happens only two lessons already
has little to your toddler machinima
local clothing she's like she sees his
blonde hair she's like hmm so I'm
actually way funnier because there are
no men with money in Los Angeles it's
not the ones that I've met good it's you
go just from that point of if you don't
trust women who are way more trustful
than men what percentage of minerals are
trusting saying yep pop my pills this
morning yeah happen we're good what
about all the side effects stuff because
obviously the pill in a way the pill
does do some good side effects stuff for
women right like it clears up your skin
or certain right like there's some of
that kind of stuff honestly I still
don't know what to believe because
there's so many different pills and
there's no way to know how it's going to
affect you until you take it I know some
that some women are fine with some women
go batshit crazy on certain pills yeah
they say some say it ups your risk of
breast cancer and cervical cancer some
say it lowers it so clearly like I said
the money is not being put into that
research as much as it is being put into
the cialis research because I still
don't know and you know I've been
dealing with the pill for many years
yeah so I don't know but maybe you know
if well first if you're both taking it
then maybe it's all good second I wonder
if this starts becoming a thing if we're
going to see a rise in sexually
transmitted infection yeah all right so
you got to the next one yeah does in
this no no perfect thank you that I mean
doesn't this lead to that I mean that
the the pregnancy thing almost is is
secondary because so many women are on
the pill and if you trust the woman
you're with and she's not going to get
pregnant basically but you're now
opening yourself up to every STD you're
opening here both of you ever we talked
about the cialis and viagra sand those
commercials always say by the way this
doesn't this doesn't protect you from
sexually transmitted diseases and we see
how those of course are are directed at
older men because those are the
gentlemen who have those issues so this
could be directed at young women because
the vibrant and still sexually I mean
and still still able to reproduce right
so once you start target and younger
guys and say by the way watch out you
might have to worry about sex transm
Zetas they care less
if Julie the old a mirror-like yeah i'm
slowing down i got my woman maybe just
one on the side and its own with no work
about pregnancy yeah for the regular you
know those older men still can reproduce
a man can it still work permit ground /
due to the minute before death the miss
firm there's a bit of a i heard i
haven't read too much research as a
certain level of a biological clock for
men where there were there's issues
maybe with your children just not right
is there just something different
between men and women here that I feel
like women are more able to be
responsible about their body that this
doesn't strike me as something that men
would even do because the woman
ultimately is the one get that gets
pregnant so there's something about this
that seems like honestly I disconnect in
general it's a huge step forward in our
society to have men be just as
accountable for pregnancy as women are
especially when it comes to changing
your biology of your body but I just
think that things happen I mean I've
been on the pill for a long time my
friends have been on the pill and I am
NOT the world's most responsible human
being I'm the worst actually at
everything I'm always late getting
places and I hair looks like I combed it
with a candy apple and all kinds of
crazy stuff happens so I don't always
trust myself and it would be amazing if
my partner whoever I word with would
also pick up some of that slack because
I'm not perfect you can can I know since
you know I'm the conspiracy there
something but this one is became the old
man because the Republican what else
when this is less on the conspiracy said
but the first thing I thought was
because I come from the point of well
what about the guys what I saw in
thinking about what they're given these
these guises the mosque the mice became
infertile for how long and is it I never
at least maybe I missed this part of the
article but it didn't seem like it was
something that was a temporary thing
it's like a permanent right so if you
stop taking it your sperm will start
working again and and those are the
things that they're gonna have to work
out how powerful that was can be yeah
well I didn't want to drop everybody
with information so it was the basic
thing
not right I didn't think if they pointed
out and the my speaking layer perfectly
photo right see that part so final
thought on this what about what about
the unintended consequences because
everything has unintended consequences
and what happens when let's say the
government of China that wants to
control population decides to put some
of this stuff in the water or you know
all kind of it opens up again a
Pandora's box of all kinds of stuff so
do we have to be afraid that this stuff
is that's the ultimate question when it
comes to progress is do we curb progress
because we're afraid it could fall into
the wrong hands or do we keep pushing
society forward and trust that people
have the best the best intentions at
heart they don't and they don't they
don't know everybody yeah conspiracy
theorists speaking it that a reason to
stop progress maybe it is maybe it won't
it's even if you want to you can as well
you know that's why was believed the
stuff that I think we're gonna star
selves humans are going to destroy
ourselves in one way or another or maybe
five different ways all at the same time